border agents bracing for an extreme
surge as the white house reportedly
plans to end a critical trump-era border
policy this summer on may 23rd
even senate democrats are sounding the
alarm over ending title 42 one border
agent worried about what will happen
saying quote it may take a few days for
the word to get out when immigrants who
make it to their final destination call
home to say they made it once people
start getting released they will call
home and let them know hey i got through
that's when you will see the crowds our
next guest is no stranger to the border
fox nation host tommy laron has gone
down there a lot she joins us now good
morning to you tommy
uh good morning thanks for having me
well thanks for coming on uh
1.7 million people have had to go back
to their countries because of title 42
and they're saying that 55 of the
migrants encountered in february were
were returned due to title 42. what will
the border look like if joe biden ends
title 42.
well listen title 42 is really the only
coveted restriction that the left is
cheerleading for us to get rid of but
it's going to be a massive run on our
border right now what you have at our
border is a free for most meaning a lot
are getting through as we know from the
footage and the wonderful bill mollusion
who reports it for us daily but when we
have the end of title 42 you're going to
see a free-for-all extravaganza there
will be a run on our border like we've
never seen before the word is going to
get out just like those border patrol
agents have said and they're expecting
to encounter about 10 to 15 000 per day
they'll be lining up ready to enter the
united states of america the only
deterrent we currently have the only
obstacle that the bite administration
has left in place is title 42. once
that's gone it's going to be an
overwhelming situation for our border
agents and those border communities and
soon our interior it's something that we
simply cannot absorb and i can't sound
the alarm about this loud enough it was
put in place on the onset of covet 19
and one of the mayors in the texas
region lower texas region south texas
don mclaughlin he's with uvalde he said
there's no plan i'm going to take a
playbook right out of black lives matter
except i'm going to change it to say
border lives matter we're going to block
that highway 90. he said he's trying to
come up with solutions because the
government's not helping he said they
have no plan what are we going to do
next last year we were calling it a
crisis this year it will be a disaster
this is the calm before the storm what
is your reaction
he's exactly right this is going to be
catch and release on steroids and these
communities simply cannot handle that
our border patrol agents are essentially
glorified babysitters as it is but when
you have thousands and thousands of
people rushing in there is no way that
these agents can handle that and i don't
believe the pine administration wants
them to i believe that the biden
administration really is setting up this
country to be an open borders nation a
free-for-all and i believe it's because
they want these people to be their
future voters but it's not safe for
americans it's not safe for migrants
we're going to see humanitarian
conditions worsen and you're going to
see our border patrol agents in a
situation that they do not want to be in
and unfortunately the bite
administration i feel will then just
demonize our agents which is completely
misplaced anger and completely wrong so
it's up to these mayors and more
importantly up to the governors of these
border states to make sure that they're
doing all that they can to stop this
because they really are our only line of
defense this administration is not
dedicated to border security and
enforcement and that is clear yeah
border patrol agrees with you some of
them are saying they feel abandoned they
feel frustrated they say we're
devastated this is going to cause chaos
tommy great to see you this morning
thank you thanks for having me you're
welcome i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainsley earhardt and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis